-I'm here with my man
Kenan Thompson.
Always funny. Congrats.
The show premieres Tuesday,
so check out "Kenan."
Now, Kenan, you've been
on some great TV shows
and in great movies
over the years,
but I want to see
if you're a big enough fan
that you can summarize a movie
or show in just five seconds.
It's time for
"5-Second Summaries."
-♪ 1, 2, 3, 4,
5-Second Summaries ♪
-Oh, here's how the game works.
We'll be given the name
of a movie or a TV show.
As soon as you see
the title in your prompter,
you'll have five seconds
to describe the plot
the best you can
and try to make me
guess what it is.
But you can't use any words
in the title,
actors' names, or catchphrases.
You're just describing
the plot of a movie
or the show in five seconds.
That sound good?
-What about the actor's
character name?
-Nope.
-All right.
-Can't do that either.
All right, here we go.
-Alright.
I'm glad I asked.
-We'll take turns.
You're going to go first.
Are you ready? And...
-Yeah, I'm ready.
-Go.
-Uh, sitting on a bench.
Alabama.
-"Forrest Gump."
-Chocolate.
-What?
-"Forrest Gump."
-Yes!
Yes!
-Sitting on a bench.
Not bad, dude.
-Yep.
-Sitting on a bench is...
-That locked it in.
-That was great.
All right. Here's mine.
-A good one.
-Can I have five seconds
on the clock?
Alright. It's there already.
Here we go.
Ready? And...go.
Oh, uh, dancing, um, heroin,
cheeseburger, France.
[ Buzzer ]
-Dancing, heroin,
cheeseburger, France.
[ Both laugh ]
I was going to say "Footloose"
just because
that's always dancing,
but cheeseburger, France?
No.
-That's the one they really
go into, dive into that.
-Yeah. Cheeseburger, France.
No, I don't know that.
-"Wonder --"
"Wonder Park." "Wonderland"?
-[ Laughs ] Wonder -- No.
Do you know what they call
a cheeseburger
in Paris, or cheeseburger
in France?
-"Pulp Fiction"?
-Yeah.
[ Bell dings ]
-"Pulp Fiction."
-All right, here we go.
Oh, I'm just getting word
from the booth.
Oh, it's in this ear.
This round, we're making it
a little tougher.
We only have three seconds
to do it.
-Oh, goody.
-Movie or TV shows.
Let's put three seconds
on the clock.
Ready?
-Alright.
-And go.
-Aah! Ssss!
Eek!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh! "Snakes on a Plane"!
[ Bell dings ]
-Boom!
-[ Laughs ]
-That's right --
I have pajama pants on
underneath my suit.
-[ Laughs ]
Are you wearing pajama pants?
-For the next scene I got to do.
-Watch you bring that back.
I'm telling you right now.
Bring it back?
Watch you start that.
That's going to be a thing.
-Yeah, pajama pants
and suits, man.
-Alright. Here we go.
You got three seconds up there.
[ Chuckles ] Here we go.
One, two. Here we go.
Oh, uh, "Kick him in the leg."
Uh...
[ Buzzer ]
-"Karate Kid."
"Karate Kid"?
[ Bell dings ]
-Ish.
-Oh, uh, uh, uh...
the, uh, the TV show is, uh,
is "Kuma Kai," "Kuma Kai,"
"Cobra Kai."
[ Bell dings ]
-We accepted "Kuma Kai."
I love it.
-"Kuma Kai."
-[ Laughs ]
I'm thinking of the Van Damme
movie -- "Bloodsport."
-Yeah, that is
a Van Damme movie.
-"Cobra Kai."
-Final round this time.
Let's put one second
on the clock. What?
Is that possible?
-Oh, God.
-This is --
Pressure's on for this one.
One second, that's barely --
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Tapping desk ]
...time to do anything.
-Mm.
-Okay.
Phew! It's about to
come on your prompter.
-Okay.
-Ready?
Go.
-Uh, nurses forever!
[ Buzzer ]
-"Cocoon"? "E.R."
-Nurses forever.
-"E.R."
-Nurses for--
-Even longer.
-Nurses for-ever?
-Yeah.
-Oh, man.
"E.R." was on for a while.
Oh, "Grey's Anatomy."
[ Bell dings ]
-See that? Look at that.
So, who wins?
-Look at that.
If anyone from
the future sees this,
look at that.
-Look at that.
-Just look at that.
You want to see something?
Watch this.
People show it, bleep-blurp it
onto their eyeglasses.
-Oh. Oh, wow.
Look at that.
He got it in one second.
-They got it in one second.
All right.
[ Clears throat ]
All right, ready? One second.
-Yeah.
-Oh. Uh, a spinning top.
[ Buzzer ]
This is --
-Spinning top.
-How would I even --
I can't describe this
in 20 minutes.
-[ Laughs ]
In 20 minutes?
I'm going with "Bridgerton."
-[ Laughs ]
No, this is -- it's a movie.
-This is a movie.
But I was thinking about
how to describe it,
and that's how I would
probably --
Without giving away anything,
that's --
Right? Spinning -- Didn't --
-"Harry Potter"?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
"Inception."
-Come on.
-"Inception."
[ Bell dings ]
The spinning top.
That's a good one.
Is it, though?
-That's a good clue.
I'm going to give you
the win on this.
Congratulations, Kenan Thompson
right there!
[ Bell dinging ]
Thank you very much.
His sitcom "Kenan" premieres
this Tuesday
at 8:30 p.m. on NBC.
Get the whole family
to watch it. It's good.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Kenan, thank you so much, pal.